je pars le matin c'est ainsi
les choses que je voyais pas mal
je pense à des choses auxquelles
je pensais pas à ça
bande annonce du film le huitième long
métrage de xavier dolan le film mathias
et maxime ovationné à cannes ce film
parle d'amour d'amitié d'authenticité
d'identité le film s'attarde en trottant
un groupe d'amis dont deux vivront une
véritable remise en question et dans
l'entrevue qu'il m'a accordée tout à
l'heure vous aviez d'hollande parle
aussi d'environnement
pour lui il est temps d'agir de
transformer l'espoir en actions
l'écoutent
bonsoir xavier dolan bonsoir vous aimez
la photo
j'aime beaucoup la photo et ça ça
représente bien le tournage puis notre
gueule
l'esprit du film du bonheur du plaisir
des jeunes où vous êtes au centre et
c'est le film d'une génération
pas seulement pour une génération mais
quand même on sent cette quête d'amitié
d'amour on va y revenir mais je vous
attrape peut vous arriver de la marche
sur le climat vous êtes prononcé souvent
sur ces questions là vous avez peur de
l'apocalypse une certaine manière à les
écrire des choses percutante au fil des
années c'était l'autre repose la
question puis qu'on me demande
d'entrevue puis qu'on me demande où tu
voles en dix ans puis souvent je fais le
lien en dix ans maintenant dix ans je
sais pas où est ce qu'on va être puis ça
fait dix ans que j'en parle de femmes
pop de façon si cultivé et puis engager
puis informés évidemment que d'une
grotte attenberg ou d'aider les vrais
scientifiques mais j'en parle peu juste
à chaque fois les gens me me disait
toujours tu faisais d'alarmisme plus
vous êtes vous êtes anxieux vous êtes
pourtant l'on dirait qu'on est vraiment
acculés au pied du mur et on est qu'on
fasse quand même a enfin on est encore
là le déni et puis à ce traité
d'alarmiste avons continué j'imagine
jusqu'à la toute fin
ouais mais en même temps greta tandberg
une jeune fille de 16 ans j'espère un
effet miroir avec vous a fait 7 ans qui
vouliez faire du cinéma dans toute
manière changer le monde et greta
tanberg effectivement encore aujourd'hui
on aujourd'hui aussi à quelqu'un qu'il
est très découvrir dès qu espéré déco
anxieuse ans est longue et
j'ai eu honte cette semaine à plusieurs
reprises des propos de certaines
personnes qui font dans le mépris dans
la facilité dans la dent dans le mais
qui sont dans le déni évidemment mais
mais ce qui est fou en fait ce qui
ressort de tout se sait à quel point
notre société n'est pas intéressée à
lire des rapports scientifiques puis
pour intéresser par les faits les faits
juste des faits c'est pas compliqué dans
la vie c'est pas une opinion c'est un
fait plus on les mélange constamment en
pensant qu'on est encore dans la lah
remous dans la alors que je veux dire on
a on a des chiffres on à défaire le des
données on pourrait ça fait 15 ans qu'on
pourrait agir pile on est dans une
situation où c'est tellement une rue
tellement cher on peut pas s'imaginer
imposer sa des indivisions contribuables
personnes vous devez voter dans la
partie vu voter pour un parti qui veut
ça mais on a un parti qui veut se venger
des champions s'il en est capable et la
science politique encore son intrus
mission hier et on on a l'impression
qu'ils ont une espèce de crin de
frilosité parce qu'on doit se faire
élire aussi puiss on impose plus de
frais fsa cote chez les oranges les
sondages ils ont des gens veulent pas
payer gens veulent que la planète ait
bien là mais si je veux être payé pour
eux parce que on a nos vies puis on a
trop de signes qui nous familles qu'on
veut se protéger pis c'est
compréhensible à plusieurs égards mais
on donc on ne réglera pas le problème
pied on va attendre que ça de nous
coûter quelques centaines dans la
baraque et ça nous coûte que la vie ou
greta
quand vous aviez 16 ans vous vous
battiez déjà pour faire votre premier
film entre les mois d'août mais
peut-être que vos messages dans vos
films permettent au sida votre manière
de vouloir changer le monde en tout cas
de réprimer certaine
certains phobie par exemple mais je
reviens greta dans la tête de quelqu'un
de 16 ans de ses tabous l'avez vécu
voici de la pluie dans le monde des
adultes et de faire votre place c'est
possible et déjà qu'il faut pas que ça
on peut faire ça généralement c'est
possible quand on ignore les gens qui
nous un qui nous disent qu'on a tort
qu'on se trompe qu'on attende à l'école
qu'on l'a pas notre place on vous disait
sa place l apal intermission de
personnes j'ai pas attendu intéressante
personne non plus je encore j'avais
patronaux des combats qui sont
complètement différents mais chacun sa
façon d'essayer de changer les choses
mais non je pense que en fait le les
chiens aboient la caravane passe
vous disiez en début d'entrevue qu' il
ya dix ans je réponde à cette question
là où je serai dans dix ans vous rendez
vous avez dit dans dix ans je devrais un
cinéaste vivant dans 30 ans est ce que
disent vos plus tard quand on regarde
dans le rétroviseur ont-ils bon dieu ça
passe et d'être mon dieu que j'en ai
vécu des courses à obstacles mon dieu
que ça a été difficile où vous souhaitez
réjouissant où ça a été qu'est ce que ça
a été peinte à que vous avez que ce
nouveau film mathias et maxime dont vous
dites c'est un film de transition c'est
un film de la maturité un film dont vous
êtes fier peut-être plus fier il ya eu
des obstacles
il ya eu des périodes plus difficiles
mais ça a été magnifique décennies le
pour moi j'ai été extrêmement privilégie
j'ai fait des films quand j'avais envie
de faire des films quand je voulais
faire des films
on m'a compagnie on me soutenu il y en a
qui ont été moins compris que d'autres
mais finalement rétrospective c'est rien
c'est comme ce genre de regel
oui il ya eu des périodes de solitude
mais je me suis fait des amis dans les
dernières années dont à qui j'ai voulu
rendre hommage à travers ce tumulte et
un film sur l'amitié qui m'ont apporté
une solidité un équilibre
une hygiène de vie beaucoup plus
solidaire beaucoup plus collective dans
l'humour dans la fratrie dans l'amitié
dans l'amour c'est un peu amoureux de
mes amis dit gg une belle vie jeu
chanceux en fait ma carte et maxime
parle de ceux qui parlent aussi de du
changement du départ il ya un personnage
principal qui est le mien qui s'en va
quelque part pendant une période de
temps indéterminée a défini et le film
se termine sur une porte qui sauva vers
le début d'un voyage pichot - puma
français maxime la fin de match c'est
maxime puis aussi une réflexion sur le
changement est ce qu'on a parce qu'on
peut changer est ce que est ce qui est
chiite et un jour dans notre vie trop
tard pour prendre le risque du
changement se dire je suis ici depuis
tant de temps jeu dans un confort
je me suis casé je me suis catégoriser
dans un cem à une certaine place est ce
que est ce que je peux bouger ce que je
peux changer du tout au tout et ce que
ça se peut est ce que j'ai pu me tromper
toutes ces années la pièce qui trop tard
pour accepter que je me suis trompé le
film parle de soute de façon assez vaste
puis pour moi parle de devoir quoi je
m'en vais au site et après dix ans de
films
je me demande souvent qu'est ce que je
fais ou est-ce que je vais qui suis-je
qu'est ce que je vais devenir
vous doutez aussi jeu tout le temps tout
le temps mais deux derrière la caméra
devant la caméra peut-être peut-être
pour prendre une pause un répit de deux
ans mais j'ai envie de jouer
oui c'est ça qu'ils m'ont arrive jouer
leur beau fils se passer ok je jouais
pour quelqu'un je veux plaire à
quelqu'un je veux que quelqu'un me
dirige même nous détestent que je viens
de faire mes critiques même manali zm
une nana surpasser momen ailleurs en
fait je n'en mène pas ailleurs j'essaye
de m'amener alliant art
mais je suis limité et puis j'ai envie
d'avoir aucune limite j'ai envie de
surtout j'ai envie d'un rythme de vie où
tout ce que je fais c'est tout ce que je
crie ne peut pas être détruit en
l'espace d'une seconde puis c'est le
code un film qui sort on leur met dans
les mains des critiques c'est la vie
c'est vrai que je critique pas cette ce
cycle là mais c'est vrai que tout
s'effondre rapidement pour un film qu'on
est meilleur auquel on a tout donné pour
lequel on acceptait de moins voir sa
famille de manquer des idées des ddd
souper avec sa mère avec ses amis pour
lequel on a renoncé à tellement de
choses puisque avec gem un profession
que je me consacre mais qu'en l'espace
d'une seconde aux prairies sur les gens
peuvent le détester ou pas le comprendre
ne pas l'aimer
j'ai envie de quelque chose d'autre j'ai
envie de jouer c'est autre chose ça la
rue poursuit la conversation avec xavier
dolan dont le film mathias et maxime
prend la fiche ces jours ci à montréal
un film de réconciliation un film sur
l'amitié mais aussi une film sur la
quête de vérité de qui on ide et de
s'assumer et ses possibles à tout moment
xavier dolan tel qu'on est
si la question que vous me posez la
question je ne sais pas si c'est
possible à tout moment c'est la question
que le film aux deux amis qui sont comme
des frères en fait qu'ils sont actions
des deux hommes depuis toujours et qui à
travers un baiser de cinéma parce qu'on
leur demande comme ça de participer un
court métrage amateur ils sont pas
acteurs ils sont peu guipy ils
s'embrassent à la cameron ont notamment
cédé n'hésite pas grave on en parlera
plus jamais et puis finalement ben on en
parle plus jamais mais ce baiser louis
xvi depuis les pousse à se remettre en
question profondément comme au niveau
des idées mais dans un chalet en étant
dans un chalet avec des amis puis je me
suis penser à ça deux amis très proches
dans un cercle très serré 2
d'amis véritable depuis le primaire le
secondaire que sage depuis longtemps
deux amis qui vivent dans la proche mans
puis tout à coup ils m'ont dit ça se
paie pas qu'on ait des sentiments l'un
pour l'autre et qu'on s'en soit jamais
rendue compte
premièrement c'est pas notre sexualité
puis deuxièmement c'est à 25 ans je
pense que qu'on se connaît puis c'est
maintenant que on y pense c'est comme ça
qu'est née qu'est née l'idée j'ai jamais
vécu ça mais j'avais envie de rendre
hommage à mes amis que j'avais envie de
raconter une histoire d'amour il fait
pour elle draine fameux l'arrivée aussi
a bien sûr que ça pourrait arriver de de
sacy mais parce qu'au fond c'est vous
qui voyez ce qui se passe deux petites
choses sur bastien et maxime sur la
quête de deux vérités aussi de s'assumer
c'est que ça prend du culot de courage
une grosse dose de courage pour ça c'est
vraiment bizarre et du courage se
remettre en question et remettre en
question ses idées et dans le personnage
de maxime star un push back si votre
personnage enfin sedan jean coutu non
c'est le nom de mon personnage
enfin dans jean coutu n'y a absolument
aucune raison de croire
cg rien de ce qui est devenu le
personnage des publicités jean coutu qui
la cachait le visage moi d'expliquer
depuis dans quelques entrevues mais je
lisais aussi que quand l école vous
fassiez prêter de tâches morin son nom
n'ont jamais vous avez jamais vues dans
un monde où c'était difficile où j'avais
vécu de l'intimidation ou wow j'ai faits
subis en tout cas déjà l'impression ce
genre de monsieur val est souvent chez
nous même au début de mon secondaire
j'étais dans une école plus difficile où
je me faisais intimider ou j'ai une
timide et aussi nos enfants ne partent
pas vraiment une semaine sans que
sans que j'y repense puissant que je
ressemble vraiment à l'aise parce que je
me sente mal de saut mais je me suis
fait traiter de machenaud parcours mais
la tâche vous l'avais dit en entrevue à
l'étoile bell puis c'est pourquoi au
fond parce que normalement les gens sur
des tours de quelqu'un qui a aucune
différence
ben oui je pense que c'est une espèce de
métaphores pour pour la blessure
profonde aussi de maxime qui est un
personnage qui a une vie très difficile
assez médiocre une vie qui veut quitter
d'ailleurs en partant en voyage puis je
pense que ça lui donne une vulnérabilité
que j'aime c'est quelqu'un qui entre
avec une grosse cicatrice qu'une telle
démarcation tout de suite on va l'avant
un peu de la douleur sa personne le sur
subit-il quand on était plus jeunes où
on devait évidemment les moqueries à
l'école on devine à quel point c'est
compliqué quand je marchais dans la rue
en pré production avec la tâche de
naissance va dans la rue
j'arrivais à réaliser qui me regardait
peuvent évidemment et des gens qui m'en
garde parce que des fois me
reconnaissent mais mais là je voyais les
gens qui me regardent des picards un
malaise en voyant cette menace et de ses
livres avec ce j'imagine en tout cas que
c'est difficile y sont je veux faire une
espèce de chien pu aller dans le
proviseur ou cissé gouët à partir d' à
partir de de maxence et maxime sont à
partir du caire ce que vous avez écrit
pour préfet vous qu'avec tout ça il ya
une très belle france d'ici qu'il dit le
succès ma compagne de sa compagne
d'isolement et avant que j'ai pu me
rendre compte j'étais à prévoir franche
et mon premier quart de siècle
seuls les trois quarts du temps ça
m'amène à parler d'un autre film que
vous avez évoqué sans nommer tantôt ma
vie avec joseph donovan qui est un film
aussi sur la solitude la célébrité
isolement elle identifie la vérité là
les absences et de swing dont vous
parlez quand ça peut être douloureux en
une seconde
or ce film la porte un message
extrêmement important est-ce que ça se
paie vous mettez dans vos films des
choses qu'on voit pas d'habitude au
cinéma puisque j'en veux pas voir ni
entendre je pense pas nécessairement je
parle de ma vérité et puis de là loin de
la vérité en général c'est ce qui
m'intéresse
les gens qui se mentent à eux-mêmes les
gens qui mentent aux autres les gens qui
cherchent leur place dans la société je
pense que c'est pas mal ce que je fais
depuis le début le cd films là dessus
après ceux des fois c'est sur une mère
et un fils dans momie d'autres fois
c'est sur un coup
dans lawrence anyways une femme
transsexuelle des fois c'est du meilleur
ami dans les amours imaginaires
c'est pas toujours les mêmes personnages
mais si souvent les mêmes enjeux des
gens qui cherchent des gens qui sont
rejetés mais en même temps quand vous
avez déjà déclaré ya dix ans parce que
dix ans quand je suis entré avec vous
quelqu'un vous aviez 8 ans vous aviez
créé leonardo dicaprio qui vous a pas
répondu
ma vie avec john f donovan c'est la
lettre mais la donne va le répondra aux
petits vous peur et c'est très un lien
d'amitié sans qu'ils se connaissent un
essor qui se rencontrer en personne mais
parce que ce personnage qui a connu le
succès que des problèmes de santé
mentale on envoie ou de toxicomanie est
bon les deux
le petit garçon de 8 ans qui devient
votre personnage vous peut être aussi
connaît la célébrité
moi j'y vois une ressemblance avec moi
sept enfants qui criaient devant les
shows télévision qui le faisait rêver
petits et puis qui ont représenté pour
moi une porte de sortie la vie au début
du secondaire que j'avais pu au malaise
que je ressentais je savais que si je
savais que que j'étais différent
j'avais dû sexuelle lost est difficile
dans le gard sont différents aussi fous
de la culture de l'est l'option des
rêves de devenir artiste sur le torse
gt gt un enfant qui avait pas eu
beaucoup de films qui avaient lu aucun
livre j'ai ça commençait à partir de là
chacun 16 ans seulement à travers une
belle-mère leblond du monde n'ont pas
ces fêtes puis non exercées sur des
plateaux doublage de tournage déjà 80
noms
oui mais j'étais un enfant qui venaient
de la banlieue qui avait une éducation
qui était ordinaire qui était pas plus
exceptionnelle que qui que ce soit puis
je n'avais jamais entendu parler d'eux
je ne lisais pas puis j'allais au cinéma
voir nemoptic semaines je serai bien
content est ce que des enfants qui vous
écrive maintenant des vidéos photos et
musique soul et je leur réponds oui je
peux pas tous la région mais
généralement en fait ma règle sais c'est
qu'on peut-être j'aimerais pouvoir avoir
le temps de répondre à tout le monde
mais je peux pas je peux pas je ne peux
pas prendre ça tend à laisser des jours
et des jours le cio un bureau à la
maison puis mes pieds je sais comme je
les aime
je salue à lui la home et lui une
correspondance stepping mais moi c'est
drôle parce que je réponds pas mais j'ai
insiste je les garde quand même eu un
bureau à dégripper de courrier puis de
mai à lagence carrière soit des lettres
d'enfants se j'essaie d'y répondre le
plus souvent je réponds aux enfants
l'enfant loupé dans le film qui devient
dur il faisait la journaliste parce que
tout ne reviendra en entrevue enfantin
en toile de fond dit on veut le
changement
non je ne mets pas tous mais surtout qui
lie la société également qu'il faut
changer
il ya le mot phobique il faut les
mobiles le sexisme tout la wii tout
autrement de leur oui mais je veux dire
oui mais ça évidemment je vous demander
si moi je suis en accord avec ce schéma
c'est le monde c'est aussi beau propos
cessé mes propos je dis c'est mes
personnages qui parlent mais c'est sûr
que je peux d'accord avec lui alors s'il
a trente ans maintenant je repose la
question qu'on pose il ya 10 ans à 20
ans vous dit je vais te cinéastes
vivants puis vivant vous l'êtes avait à
travers ce film mais à 40 ans mais ce
qui est malheureux c'est que vous me
posez la même question qui ma réponse
est encore plus me poser la question à
10 ans mais évidemment le monde est loin
de voir ce que le savoir c'est que vous
êtes nourrit d'espoir d'inquiétude et
d'espoir au front mais en tout cas
j'avais beaucoup d'espoir à l'époque
quand je vous ai dit ce même si j'avais
une inquiétude en fait j'ai encore de
l'espoir mais mon inquiétude est plus
grand et puis comment le film se faisant
tourner - nous empêcherait de faire
passer ce que vous avez à dire dans le
jeu mais j'ai envie de faire c'est
justement dans la trentaine j'ai envie
de m'engager de façon plus active dans
ma société dans des oeuvres de charité
et dans des dents des organisations d'en
décider
il ya les films puis ça c'est bien ça me
change un peu moi ça change ma vie puis
je parle de mes petits problèmes puis
deux évidemment c'est les petits
problèmes de plusieurs autres personnes
aussi mais logique pense que j'ai
l'ambition de peut-être m'engager de
façon un peu moins cinématographique
puis un peu plus loin le plus
existentielles alors je me laissais on
va laisser le public découvrir votre
génération à travers mathias et maxime
pour des adultes d'autres générations
c'est une grande découverte donc au
cinéma dès le 9 octobre et d'ici là vous
faites la tournée oui on vous souhaite
que du bonheur merci beaucoup merci la
vie